the queen actually didn't meet Kate and
until sort of eight or nine years into
her courtship with Prince William and of
course she met Megan farsina because it
was a much faster courtship but she
really went out of her way to be
incredibly warm and welcoming to to both
her granddaughters-in-law we saw that I
suppose in a public capacity when she
took Kate to Leicester I remember being
on that trip it was during the Queen's
Diamond Jubilee year and it was the
first time the queen had ever taken Kate
on an engagement and it was very obvious
that she was showing her how one does
this Royal role on the road and it was
wonderful to watch and of course she
took Megan on the Royal train to Chester
and again all part of this preparation
for the future I remember being told by
one Palisade that the queen had invited
Kate to go to Bucking Palace to meet
with her ladies and waiting to go
through the Royal archives so that she
could prepare for her royal wedding and
of course for the role that she was
going to inherit so I think the queen
was very mindful about preparing these
young women but also making sure that
the door was always open whether it was
for tea whether it was for a chat and it
always was and Kate became Incredibly
Close to the queen I think you know as
the Prince of Wales said in his
statement he he felt hugely grateful
that his family got to spend so much
time with the queen I mean Kate had 20
years to really get to know the Monarch
what a privilege as a future Queen
consort hugely important as well but not
just that the queen had a lot of time
with her great grandchildren the queen
would Host this wonderful sleepover at
Balmoral in August and invite all of the
grandchildren and the great
grandchildren and she looked forward to
that weekend I think probably more than
any other it was always noisy when
Prince Philip was still alive he made
sure he wasn't around because there were
too many screaming children but the
queen absolutely loved it and I I think
it was massively important to her that
she got to spend that time with her
family the queen was the ultimate
working mum she didn't always have time
to be with her children so I think she
made sure that she treasured those
relationships with her grandchildren and
she was overjoyed to have it all over
again with their children her great
grandchildren